hi everyone I am Amy whoa whoa
I go by sailor HG on the Internet I am a
creative tech
just currently focused on making
computer science more accessible through
illustrated scenes called bubblesort
themes and today I'm going to talk about
image compression and glitching so it's
funny how the imperfections of a medium
can sometimes be what is most calming
about it light leaks or film grain or
the slight discoloration of an vignette
effect of Polaroid photos are all
imperfections of analog cameras and even
though digital cameras can avoid all of
these imperfections we purposely apply
them via Instagram or other photo app
filters now there are imperfections but
they add character and nostalgia so
fast-forwarding a little bit digital
mediums still have charming
imperfections albeit different ones for
example glitching every once in a while
my computer will accidentally delight me
by doing something like this and making
digital media has now been around long
enough that this glitching aesthetic can
be considered nostalgic I'm just like we
can create image filters to mimic light
leaks and other analog camera
imperfections how can we create image
filters that apply these glitchy digital
imperfections artistically onto an image
before talking about how to apply
glitching filters to an image let's
start a little further back with images
and image file formats so what is an
image a digital image is color
information that has been sampled at
regular intervals it's composed of rows
and columns of squares of a single color
each called pixels we can represent the
color of each pixel with three numbers
often the three numbers we use are the
amount of red green and blue in that
color but it could be also be some other
three numbers like hue saturation and
value so this sequential pixel color
information preceded by headers
containing additional image information
like the width and height of the image
and the color space is the most
straightforward file format for images
known as a bitmap or BMP let's say we
want to glitch this kind of image data
there are a few different options for
glitching an image when you're working
with a pixel of data itself for example
you can soar rows or columns
of the pixels for an interesting glitch
effect and an example of that is on the
left you can also shift random sections
of pixels or just shift certain color
channels of sections of pixels since all
the color data is separate an example of
doing something like that is on the
right and on a demo an example of a
pixel level glitching apps that I wrote
that randomly shifts a single color
channel of random sections of pixels and
does this a couple different times
so here we have an image and when we
apply a glitch effect to it does
something like this
but most images aren't actually stored
in this straightforward way since images
are information like any other pieces of
information if we want them to take up
less space which we usually do we can
compress them how do we compress images
as a quick refresher compression is
reducing the amount of space it takes to
store information while still keeping
its meaning discernible in the top
example we reduce the number of
characters in the message by eliminating
redundancies we combine repeated
characters and indicate how many of them
are repeated in a row it's lost this
compression because we can create the
original using the compressed
information so nothing is lost in the
bottom example we reduce the number of
characters in the message by removing
vowels spaces and punctuation
we can't tell for sure what the original
message was but we can make a good guess
from context this kind of compression is
called lossy because we can't recreate
the original using the compressed
information something was lost what
information can we remove from an image
without us being able to notice much of
the difference let's look at the JPEG
file format and what kinds of
compression methods it uses JPEG is a
common image file format especially for
photos and often can reduce the file
size to one tenth of the original with
almost no perceptible change the main
theme of the main underlying theme of
JPEG compression is separating out
information into layers that contain
less - more details imagine that you
could separate a drawing into background
silhouette color blocks rough details
and then line art what is the benefit of
this let's look at the least detailed
layer the background the background will
require very little space to store it's
just a single solid color so separating
it out means that we can store it using
less space than the other layers now
let's look at the most detailed layer
and that outlines the image is still
recognizable without it at one level of
detail lower the rough details layer you
can still get a pretty good sense of
what the image is so depending on how
much space you want the image to
you can decide to include or not include
the more detail there's we aren't able
to do this exactly but we do something
similar when compressing JPEGs you'll
notice that the most detail the most
compressed example on the right we've
lost a lot of detail compared to the
highest-quality example on the left in
other words we threw away detail to make
the file smaller so how does JPEG
separate an image into layers of varying
amounts of detail in order to have a
better idea of what can be thrown away
one way that JPEG compression separates
the information into more and less
detailed layers of information is
through color let's take a look at
separating an image into red green and
blue layers each one of these layers
looks like it contains about the same
amount of detailed information so this
isn't very helpful instead let's try
separating it into luminance blue green
and red green channels by the way the
luminance channel is an average of the
red green and blue layers so all three
channels put together still contain all
the same information as the RGB channels
the luminance channel contains the most
details it looks like there are far less
details distinguishable in the blue
green and red green channels and this is
because our eyes aren't as good at
detecting differences in these channels
so we can store the blue green and red
green channels with less space than we
do the luminance channel similar to our
solid background in the earlier example
in fact we could keep only half of the
resolution of the blue green and red
green channels and not notice that much
of a difference in the overall quality
of the image color isn't the only way we
can separate an image into layers with
more in less details we can use
something called the discrete cosine
transform to separate an image into
higher and lower frequency components
what do we mean by higher and lower
frequency components let's use the
metaphor of a sound file that's a
recording of a string quartet so I
played violin in a string quartet
throughout high school in college but I
had a lot of friends who play the viola
and cello
who often complained about getting
boring parts compared to the violin
parts and it seemed true that the lower
the notes an instrument played often the
less complicated and detailed the parts
that they were given let's say that we
have a recording of a string quartet and
let's say that we want to separate it in
two layers of different instruments we
want to separate the violins into their
own track the violist
into their own track and the cellist
into their own track we can pass the
sound file of the recording through
filters that only let certain frequency
ranges through and not others we know
that that frequency range about violins
is about 196 Hertz to three thousand one
hundred thirty six Hertz and the
frequency range of a cello is about
sixty five Hertz to nine hundred eighty
eight Hertz and because there's some
overlap it won't be an exact separation
of instruments it'll just be approximate
and if we do this will separate the
recording not only in two separate
instruments each playing at higher lower
frequencies but we've separated the
recording into tracks with more and less
details because the higher pitched
instruments tend to have them more
complicated parts so we want to do the
same thing for an image we want to run
an image through filters that will
separate it out in two layers of higher
and lower frequencies but while we can
do that for a sound file how do we do
that for an image well let's take a look
at what a sound file looks like visually
the example is something like on the top
and then when visualized the luminosity
value of each pixel in a row of pixels
looks something like the image on the
bottom
since the luminosity value of a pixel is
some arbitrary number between 0 and 255
so we're actually not that different
looking they're both signals they're
both waveforms and we can treat them
both like waves and just like we can
separate a recording of a quartet into
separate layers of different frequency
ranges we can separate an image into
separate layers of different frequencies
the official mathematical name for this
process of separating separating out all
the different frequencies of a signal is
called a Fourier transform free--ah was
a French scientist who in 1822 claimed
that any wave can be expressed as a sum
of pure sine waves of different
amplitudes frequencies and phase shifts
and this was later proven to only be
true under certain circumstances but it
does work in our case on this diagram
maybe helps illustrate it
these simple sine waves of varying
frequencies amplitudes and phase shifts
can be added together to form a more
complicated sine wave and the reverse is
also true any wave including complicated
ones can be expressed as a sum of many
pure sine waves of varying frequencies
amplitudes and phase shifts because
image data is discrete not continuous
that is it's only ever integers and it's
color data sampled at distinct points
each pixel we can use a special discrete
version of the Fourier transform called
the discrete cosine transform to show
how it works
let's use a simple toy example let's say
that we have greyscale data for an image
8 pixels wide and since the range of
data is from 0 to 255 we can subtract
all of the data by 128 so that it's
centered on the origin the same way that
the cosine is so our end goal is that we
want to split up our graph into a bunch
of pure sine or cosine waves of
different frequencies that one added
together become that graph since we're
working with 8 pixel values here are all
the possible pure cosine functions that
could make it up each with a frequency
between 0 to 7 half cycles in the range
that we're working with and in case it's
unclear how these functions are cosines
remember that we're only working with
eight points so we're sampling the
cosine at each of these eight points to
come up with these graphs you can see
that for the third pure frequency graph
there are three half cycles of the
cosine graph on 4/7 our seventh pure
frequency graph there are seven half
cycles of the cosine graph so how can we
figure out which of these cosines of
different frequencies and in what
quantities to add together to get our
original graph this equation
in Milan scary but it's okay the
computer can calculate it for you
many image processing or signal
processing libraries contain a method to
compute just equations so this graph
looks pretty similar to our original
graph of pixel values shifted by 128 but
instead of being a graph of pixel
grayscale values it's a graph of how
many of each pure cosine wave we need to
add together to get our original graph
of pixel grayscale values what is the
point of this we have the exact same
amount of information as before we
didn't save any information well not yet
in our original graph all of the items
in the graph were equally valuable but
in our new graph even though it has the
same number of items as before the items
on the right the higher frequency items
are less valuable because they contain
the details so we can remove more and
more of them starting from the rightmost
one to save space if we want to since
images are 2d and not 1d to calculate
the DCT for an image we can apply the
same principles as our 1d example but in
2d so starting with our tiny image
example say that instead of a row of
eight pixels we have an 8 by 8 pixel
image to separate this image in two
layers of different frequencies we use
2d basis functions instead of our 1d
cosine functions this is what the 2d
basis functions look like each entry of
the 2d array basis function each each
entry of that 2d array is a separate
basis function you can think of each 2d
basis function as a surface white
represents a value of 1 and black
represents a value of negative 1 and the
image that we have here is kind of like
an overhead view of the graph of these
functions the zero zero and tree looks
thought on the top and leftmost graphs
look kind of like top-down views of a
pure sine surface and just like before
we want to calculate what coefficients
of each of these basis functions we
would need to add up together to form
our original pixel grayscale data and
when we do calculate these coefficients
instead of a list of eight coefficients
we end up with a matrix of eight by
eight coefficient
something like this this is an example
of what the commuted computed
coefficients of basis functions might
look like each of these numbers combined
with its corresponding basis function
from the original graphic added up will
make our original 8x8 image notice that
the numbers tend to get closer to zero
for the higher frequency components this
lines up with our idea that the higher
frequency components don't contribute as
much to the image so if we need to save
space it's okay to get rid of those but
exactly how many of them should we get
rid of to figure out exactly how many of
the coefficients to keep and how many to
get rid of we use a quantization matrix
a matrix which will be different based
on the JPEG quality setting you'll
notice that the higher that the
quantization matrix has higher numbers
for the higher frequency components so
we'll divide the coefficient from the
previous matrix by its corresponding
entry in the quantization matrix and
then round to the nearest integer and
that might give us something like this
doing this calculation we've gotten rid
of a large number of the higher
frequency components we still have to
store their values as zero but as we saw
in our earliest example of compression
repeated values make information much
easier to compress we used an 8 by 8
image as an example for simplicity but
it turns out that for a larger image we
still actually break up the image into 8
by 8 sections and apply this method to
each of those 8 by 8 sections the reason
is at the time that JPEG was created the
equation to calculate the coefficients
was computationally intensive and became
more expensive the larger the section it
was applied to so doing it on 8 by 8
sections was what researchers consider
the largest section size that didn't
take too long so how can we use
knowledge of how JPEG works to purposely
create glitchy effects on an image
well one glitchy effect comes free with
the JPEG image compression algorithm
it's called artifacting and it shows up
when you set the quality promoter
the parameter - really low which means
that each group of 8 by 8 pixels is
throwing away a lot of its details and
since each group of 8 by 8 pixels is
being processed separately they may not
no longer perfectly align with each
other in their content and this is how
the edges of the 8x8 blocks become
really visible also because within each
block sharp edges are being approximated
by some of the functions cosines you
might see halos or oscillations around
sharp edges another way to cause
glitching in a JPEG is using the
original source of a lot of glitching
that is data corruption what happens
when we manually curve up to the data of
a JPEG file well if we're doing it
manually
we want to be careful to specifically
avoid touching the header information or
any other information that will mean
that the file is not recognized as a
JPEG anymore so we only want to modify
the compressed image data itself each of
these sections has a marker according to
the JPEG specification so we can scan
the image file for the marker for that
section and only modify the data between
it and the end of the image file
incidentally the marker for this area is
FF da we can convert the image data to
byte data readable as hex and at a
random location in the compressed image
data we can replace a single byte with
another randomly generated byte and we
can repeat this for as many glitches as
we like because the speck of a jpg
renderer only tells a renderer what to
do with correct data renderers each have
different ways of handling what data is
incorrect so we have modified exactly
one byte in each of these images and we
can see that a JPEG with one randomly
corrupted by it looks different in
Safari where the error stops after one
row and chrome where that error travels
through the rest of the image so to save
space the constant component of each
block in a JPEG that is the coefficient
of the zero zero basis function for that
block is based on the difference between
it in the previous blocks so chrome
might be carrying that error forward in
Safari the error stops after one row to
render the
maybe safari just starts from scratch
and doesn't look at the previous row
how can modifying a single bite
sometimes result in a color change well
when we modify a random byte of data in
the image data since color channel data
is separate for each block we might only
affect one of the color channels leading
to a completely different color and in
the case of Chrome it would continue for
the rest of the image
how does modifying a single byte
sometimes result in a position shift
well each 8 by 8 block of JPEG data
contains information about its overall
position in the image and if we modify a
random byte of the image data we might
affect the location information and
cause the JPEG renderer to draw that
block in a different place so after
learning about all these ways to glitch
data JPEG data specifically and played
around with them I settled on a
combination of artifacting and random
manual data corruption of compressed
image information so now I'll show a
demo in a couple of different browsers
and renderer since it'll look different
image
okay so this example is with chrome this
is me and my cut so first I will
artifact it and then apply the glitch to
it also super interesting thing is the
OS preview renderer is different so if
you open it up it'll look like this so
you can like actually see all the basis
functions in here which is pretty cool
so yeah it's completely different
behavior and each
okay so if you would like to play with
those glitches yourself you can find
them at sailor HT comm slash glitchy or
sailor HD comm slash the G / - dot HTML
for the JPEG specific ones and they
don't currently work very well on mobile
sorry so you'll have to look at them on
a desktop but yeah thanks for having me
and come talk to me if you want to talk
about images or glitching or computer
science education thank you
[Applause]